hey youtubers it's Charlie so Deadpool
owns the Avengers what the hell does
that mean what is Marvel doing with the
comics so currently there are three
different Avengers teams in the comics
there's the main team that is funded or
not funded by Tony Stark I'll explain
that in a second the New Avengers team
is called Avengers idea mechanics that's
a whole different roster then there's
Avengers unity division which is the
Deadpool team the one the Deadpool is
funding so there are three different
Avengers books right now with three
different teams but I'm only following
the Deadpool team in the Ironman team
I'm not really interested in the aim
Avengers team right now it just it's not
super interesting compared to what
they're doing with the other two books
so what happened to the Marvel Universe
why is Deadpool so rich now and why is
Tony Stark so poor and why do they have
two completely different Avengers teams
well it's largely because there was a
big falling out between Falcon and Steve
Rogers now Steve Rogers a long time ago
passed the mantle of Captain America
past the shield to Sam Wilson and he
became the new Captain America they had
a big falling out during x-men access
through Secret Wars and so they are
definitely not best buds anymore Tony
Stark also originally left the Avengers
a while ago when he went to join the
guardians of the galaxy
so the Steve Rogers Captain America
created the Avengers unity team which is
a combination of some of the old
Avengers some of the old x-men and some
of the Inhumans so it's a way to honor
this ongoing peace in the wake of what
happened during the access storyline the
reason Deadpool is on the team is
because he bought his way on he is now
funding that Avengers team they're
operating like a normal Avengers team
would the Tony Stark Avengers which are
just called the regular Avengers are
basically the underfunded team they're
operating out of this really small
warehouse they have half the gear Tony
Stark had to sell off the Avengers Tower
because he doesn't have any cash what
the hell happened how can they don't
have any toys well one I think they
wanted to take some of the steam out of
the character billionaire playboy
philanthropist like every once in a
while you have to take the piss out of
Tony Stark so they took his cash away
and they explained that he just he
wasn't running his company when he was
out in space with the guardians of the
galaxy so they basically say that while
Iron Man was away his company started to
languish he came back and the company is
in ruins so he's kind of in a rebuilding
phase but he needs to operate the
Avengers the Avengers are still very
important but because of the big schism
with Steve Rogers he has to pick new
people
that's where Kamala Khan comes in and I
think the extra reason for wanting to
keep Tony Stark poor is because they
want the book to feel like the backyard
Avengers like the cosplaying Avengers
you have a bunch of noobs a bunch of
kids on the team just having fun just
being really happy about being Avengers
and doing good things so now for all
intents and purposes Deadpool
owns what you would think of is the main
Avengers team although technically Iron
Man's team is the main Avengers team
it's just the Deadpool's team looks like
the real of interest team because they
have all the money so the next big WTF
is where to held the Deadpool get all
this money yeah he's an assassin but he
almost always kills the people that hire
him and then there are other times when
he's on x-force for instance where
Warren Worthington where angel is
funding the team because he's super rich
too Deadpool refuses to take payment on
the grounds of moral objections so he
almost never gets paid for doing
anything because this uncanny Avengers
team is a Deadpool book now it feels a
lot like a Deadpool story so there's a
lot of silliness going on it doesn't
take itself super seriously and they're
just saying that Deadpool is using his
celebrity to fund the team now the other
thing is that he's still married to
shkolu he is super rich so he's probably
getting some money from her too but
wouldn't it be crazy if they tried to do
some of that in the x-force movie where
Deadpool funds the x-force team I don't
think you would get that ridiculous
they probably played a little straighter
so they'd be getting some funds from
Professor X I like the way the movies
never really addressed that either he
just super rich has this giant mansion
with a bunch of toys just infinite
wealth the same way Tony Stark has
infinite wealth in the movies to the
comics tend to have a little bit more
fun with that idea as you can see but
let me know if you'd like to see them do
stuff like this in the movies but take
Iron Man's money away make him poor take
a lot of his toys away or make Deadpool
super rich so he can fund his own team -
I think he is at least one sequel away
from forming a team like will see the
Deadpool sequel then we'll see x-force
and even then spiritually that'll still
be connected to x-men so if x-force does
get a super cool base super cool toys
it'll probably flow from x-men bank
accounts if you want to read some of the
new Deadpool comics the main the main
title just a regular Deadpool comic is
pretty good right now
uncanny Avengers is kind of fun I like
the ardent Deadpool more than I like the
ardent uncanny Avengers but if you want
to read an Avengers book I would
definitely read the regular title of the
Iron Man team and invincible
Ironman is also a really awesome comic
book right now - it's crazy to think how
even like 15 years ago nobody gave a
about Ironman even even in the
comics he wasn't that popular it wasn't
until after that first Iron Man movie
that he really blew up in the comics but
I'm really excited to see what happens
to Deadpool now that his movies are
blowing up - he was already a big
cash-grab character so he's always been
super popular in the comics so I don't
know that it's gonna affect him that
much you'll probably just see him become
a bigger part of comic book stories that
he appears in instead of just being like
a little side character so in related
comic book news I just did a Batman V
Superman video that was a new teaser and
talked about some of the deleted scenes
I'm gonna be doing a Star Wars video
that's kind of like that - they're
releasing a bunch of bonus features on
the DVD and there's a trailer for it be
sure to subscribe to get it and if
there's any other Deadpool videos you
guys want me to do or any comic book
videos just let me know I don't do a lot
of comic book specific videos because
most of you are mostly just familiar
with the movie and the TV stuff but
every once in a while I try to talk
about comics if it's really funny while
you guys wait for me to post that Star
Wars video you can click here to learn
about the Batman V Superman deleted
scenes and you can click here to learn
all about Deadpool becoming the Iron Man
of the x-men universe thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight
you